what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to do a first
time watching for the film A Few Good
Men John are you doing good I am doing
great and I am a men aha that is good to
hear my friend Tom Cruise is in the SEO
and this has been one of the top movies
on our list for a while so we were like
Now's the Time to capitalize on it but
before we go into that today's video is
sponsored by
nobody nobody is sponsoring this why not
well you want the truth John you guys
would skip it anyway so it doesn't
matter oh that's right that's all we
know about this movie is that one
question forever through little children
but yeah guys I love me some Aaron
Sorkin so I'm really late to checking
this out leave a like on this video
that'd be very much appreciated also as
always full and stretch and watch along
recycle with your own copy of a Few Good
Men available for a super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page we cover
several things exclusively over there
with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included thank you to all who
have joined thus far becoming super sexy
rejects let's swing into action and see
all the crazy stunts he does in the
court cases
[Music]
Gary Marshall direct this I forget who
directed it no I couldn't tell you you
just reminded me was Aaron Sorkin yeah
this is his first movie whoa adapted
from his play okay I know some facts
behind the scenes about it
highway to the danger zone
this is gonna be fun
I was like is this a hazing or is this
like an actual assault
[Music]
jeezing lock the door
I mean you know Rob Ryan Rob Ryan Rob
Marshall and I was like no way that
can't be Rob Marshall
this is a weird Choice Gary Marshalls
would be interesting as well but I think
Rob Reiner makes the most that makes
more sense such for the time
God damn the timing
[Applause]
well-oiled machine Precision this is how
Marine's battle
yes it's just a battle of wits and
postures
Captain I'd like to request that it be
me who's the attorney no I'd like to
request that it be I who I'm assigned
that's that's confidence inspiring
is she like a Jag entered the barracks
room of a PFC Williams Santiago and
assaulted him Santiago died at the base
Hospital approximately an hour later
what Jesus
Dawson and Downey are both recruiting
poster Marines I was thinking it sounded
an awful lot like a code red code red
I'd like to have them moved up to
Washington and assign Council in short
Captain I'd like to suggest that
I'd be the one who that that it be me
you're a woman
practicing the law she's not cut out for
litigation she's a hell of an
investigator Jerry an internal Affair
sure she can crawl up a lawyer's ass
with the best of them when it comes to
trial work I think I know I know all
passion no Street Sports bring her back
again cool we projected the thing about
it being a woman so we are the Sexes
they don't even care yeah they're just
talking about her abilities
well from what I understand from your
colleagues you're much too valuable in
your present assignment to be wasted
when I'm sure a ball down to a
five-minute plea bar in a week's worth
of paperwork she's got passion I promise
you divisional sign the right man for
the job
all right let's go let's get to Jack
Reacher that's right military Mountain
Jack Reacher I'm gonna charge him with
possession and being under the influence
while on duty you plead guilty it was
oregano Dave it was ten dollars worth of
oregano yeah well your client thought it
was marijuana my client's a [__] that's
not against the law
I'm gonna file against pre-trial
confinement and you're going to spend
the next three months going blind on
paperwork because the signalman second
class bought and smoked a dime bag of
oregano even in the Navy plays by his
own rules
Tom Cruise before he fixed the nose
eyebrows and teeth
that's right man the raw ball of clay a
marine Corporal named Dawson illegally
fires around from his weapon over the
fence line and into Cuban territory
what's your fence line a big wall
separating the good guys from the bad
guys
teacher's pet
now do your Christopher Walken
impression go into Santiago's room stuff
a rag down his throat and an hour later
Santiago's dead attending physician says
a rag was treated with some kind of
toxin Jesus Daniel Caffey I was told to
meet with uh
Commander Galloway
himself what a mess he seems like a
slacker how long have you been in the
Navy going on nine months now and how
long have you been out of law school a
little over a year
or about 10 000 apples when I petitioned
division to have counselor Sons I was
hoping I would be taken seriously come
on your Lieutenant captions generally
considered the best litigator in our
office he successfully plea bargained in
44 cases in nine months wow
one of the people we'll be seeing down
there is the Barrack CEO Colonel Nathan
Jessup I assume you've heard of him who
hasn't it no he's been in the papers
lately he's expected to be appointed
director of operations and National
Security Council these are the letters
letters and months at gitmo
it's Guantanamo Bay
where he offered information about
Corporal Dawson's fence line shooting in
exchange for a transfer this letter
makes it look like your client had a
motive to kill Santiago got you and
Santiago is
the victim write that down
write that down I'll get them to drop
the conspiracy and conduct on becoming
12 years you haven't talked to a witness
or looked at a piece of paper pretty
impressive huh
Commander do you have some sort of
jurisdiction here that I should know
about I'm special counsel for internal
affairs so my jurisdictions pretty much
in your face
yeah oh she emphasized the diction part
slap him with it sure you're dismissed
I always forget that part yeah he's too
cool for school don't worry he's gonna
learn to Care by the end of this move
yeah follow every rule to the T I'm
writing to inform you of my problems
with my unit here in Cuba I've fallen
out of runs before for several reasons
such as feeling dizzy or nauseated I've
fallen back about 20 or 30 yards woof my
sergeant grabbed me and pushed me down
the hill then I saw a black and the last
thing I remember is hitting the deck
whoa I wanted to provide you my
information about Eagle fence line
shooting that occurred the night of
August the 2nd oh boy who the [__] is
PFC William T Santiago God I missed Jack
Nicholson I think Santiago should be
transferred off the base immediately yes
wait I've got a better idea toxins suck
maybe we have a responsibility as
officers to train Santiago yes I'm
certain that I read that somewhere once
[Laughter]
why don't we meet at the old club and
have lunch and we'll talk about the
training of young William I'd be
delighted to hear any suggestions that
you might have sir dismissed I love you
sir there's just no one like Jack
Nicholson I know it's the scratch of his
voice that drawl we went to the academy
together but I've been promoted up
through the chain with greater speed and
success than you have if that's a source
of tension or embarrassment for you I
don't give a [__] I really believe that
yeah but I don't think you're fit to
handle the defense it takes someone
hours to discover I'm not fit to handle
the defense
it's especially Discerning you went to
Harvard Law then you joined the Navy and
now you're just treading water for the
three years you've got to serve in the
Jag core just kind of laying low so you
can get out and get a real job if that's
a situation that's fine I won't tell
anyone hot shot but if this case is
handling the same fast food slick ass
Persian bizarre Manner and something's
going to get missed and I wouldn't be
doing my job if I allowed Dawson and
Downing to spend any more time in prison
than absolutely necessary because their
attorney had predetermined the path of
least resistance woof
the doctor's report says that Santiago
died of asphyxiation brought on by acute
lactic acidosis and that the nature of
the acidosis strongly suggests poisoning
now I don't know what that means but it
sounds pretty bad
I'm gonna talk to your supervisor I was
assigned by division remember somebody
over there thinks I'm a pretty good
lawyer so well I appreciate your
interest and admire your enthusiasm I
think I can handle things myself
including the truth just when you
thought he had a lack of daisiac quality
yeah that's right there's duplicitous in
there sir code red is a disciplinary
engagement so a marine falls out of line
it's up to the men in his unit to get
him back on track Garden variety typical
what's basic Code Red
the men in his Squad would give him a GI
shower scrub brushes brillo pads steel
wool wow was the attack on Santiago
kodron yes sir the rag you stuff in
Santiago's mouth was a poison on it no
sir we were just gonna shave his head
sir where'd you get the rag train him to
think of his unit before himself to
respect the code what's the code unit
core God country I beg your pardon
linear priorities
tune Commander Lieutenant Jonathan
Kendrick held a meeting with the men and
specifically told them not to touch
Santiago it's important information
I'm going to Cuba with you tomorrow and
the hits just keep on coming where's Tom
Cruise to go back to just being an actor
I know I love what he does now but but
yeah it's like about the performance
it's about him inhabiting a role and
he's playing a guy and he doesn't have
all the action to nothing rest on that
but yeah
and that's not the priority Jack Russ
came to see me today he offered me the
12 years I mean I guess
I'll take it up oh no he's starting to
care more something doesn't feel right
okay
he said the platoon Commander Lieutenant
Jonathan Kendrick had a meeting with the
men and specifically told him not to
touch Santiago I never mentioned
Kendrick I don't even know who he is
keep pulling the thread there's more
than meets the eye maybe instead of a
running Montage we'll get a reading
Montage how the hell is your dad Danny
he passed away seven years ago sir
that's not what I feel like the [__]
[__]
there's a lot of really great injection
to humans yeah it's definitely got like
a surprising wit about it I mean I guess
you'd expect that from Sorkin but at the
same time I thought this would be like
heavy
his involvement I mean it seems to me
that Jack Nicholson definitely
orchestrated this kill yeah I mean
that's how it feels yeah especially with
like the way he was talking in that
first scene seemed a little unhinged
Santiago is going to reveal the person's
name in exchange for a transfer yes any
details that I'm missing you should feel
free to speak up
thank you
damn look at that game of cat and mouse
game on we agreed that for his own
safety Santiago should be transferred
off the base on the first available
flight to the States oh 600 the next
morning oh come on dude
code red still happened on this on the
spacecraft Joe the kernel doesn't need
to answer
no she outranks you Danny
I want to tell you something
I would defeated
caution in your tone Commander I'm a
fair guy but this heat is making me
absolutely crazy
I eat breakfast 300 yards from 4 000
Cubans who were trained to kill me so
don't think for one second that you can
come down here flash a badge and make me
nervous
holy hell never get nervous you can have
all the transfer orders that you want
you have to ask me nicely
Jesus Christ power games of this guy
Colonel Jessup it's not too much trouble
I'd like a copy of the transfer order
sir
no problem
loves to maintain that power it's a
little Heart of Darkness right down here
in Cuba Carl markinson's gone UA
unauthorized absence did Lieutenant
Kendrick order you guys to give Santiago
a code red yes sir there it is
PewDiePie she's not gonna win you a
place in my hardcore well I get paid no
matter how much time you spend in jail
yes sir I know you do sir oh he's you
Harold whoa
Jesus and then he went into Dodson
Danny's room and specifically told him
to give him a code red it's not what
Kendrick's Kendrick's alive you have
proof I have the defendants and I have
23 Marines who aren't accused of
murdering a lieutenant with four letters
of commendation that is a people battle
right there yeah you know what markinson
did for the first 17 of his 26 years in
the core counterintelligence markinson's
gone there is no Parkinson
we did nothing wrong sir we did our job
and if that has consequences then I'll
accept him and I won't say that I'm
guilty sir exactly good on you the Court
decides that what we did was wrong then
I'll accept whatever punishment they
give I believe I did my job and I will
not dishonor myself my unit or the core
so I can go home in six months sir
this guy's good too Harold I did
everything I could you're going to
Leavenworth for the better part of your
life and you know what I don't give a
[__] yeah you do what happened to
saluting an officer when he leaves the
room
[Music]
he knows Danny doesn't care about code
yeah you know nothing about the law
you're an ambulance chaser with a rank
you're nothing
live with that shots fired wow it
doesn't look like you wanted the truth
there Danny it does look like you could
handle it
the accuser charged with murder
conspiracy to commit murder and conduct
on becoming a United States Marine the
defense will stand to replace yeah
inspiration
he said yeah not yes sir
they're not guilty there it is
a man what is a lieutenant Junior grade
with nine months experience and a track
record for plea bargaining get assigned
a murder case so you can roll over yeah
would it be so that it never sees the
inside of a courtroom exactly
no wonder they chose me Joe before you
come over and I pick up a carton of
legal pads half a dozen boxes red pens
half a dozen boxes oh he is focused
look at this
friend at the NIS she said if Martinson
doesn't want to be found We're not gonna
find him he said I could be Mark and
Shannon you wouldn't know it are you are
you markinson
you can see how there's a play but this
feels very cinematic a lot of times
movies that are based on plays feel like
a play but this feels like a film now
Lieutenant Kathy is going to astonish
you with stories of rituals and Dazzle
you with official sounding terms like
code red you might even try to cut into
a few officers for you oh my God he's
doing the Eminem Eight Mile thing okay
you have a dumb friend named Chatterbox
Own It All
in every weak point when Dawson and
Downey went into Santiago's room that
night it wasn't because of Vengeance or
hatred it's because it was what they
were ordered to do
but if you're a marine you're given an
order you follow it or you pack your
bags Harold Dawson and Loudoun down here
sitting before you today because they
did their job nice nicely done a member
of private Santiago's Union had
illegally fired his weapon over the
fence line the shift reported only one
century returned his weapon to the
switch with a round of ammunition
missing lance corporal Harold Dawson
this guy's believably boring yep
expert witness
Corporal Carl Edward hammacher Marine
Barracks rifle security company Windward
platoon Bravo is that Cuba Gooding Jr
Kendrick held on the afternoon of
September 6 with the members of the
second platoon yes sir it is show me the
money
[Laughter]
did Lieutenant Kendrick leave a standing
order at that meeting yes sir what was
it sorry said Santiago wasn't to be
touched
five minutes after this meeting no sir
thanks I have no more questions
slim narrative
clear-cut the facts the defense is
willing to concede that all 22 witnesses
will testify substantially as Corporal
hammacher did if the government is
willing to concede that none of them
were in Dawson and Downey's room in 1620
on September 6th yeah cut through the
fair trade
cut through the fat if the muscles and
other cells of the body burn sugar
instead of oxygen lactic acid is
produced that lactic acid is what caused
Santiago's lungs to bleed gross Willie
Santiago dive poisoning absolutely
dozens of toxins which are virtually
undetectable the nature of the acidosis
is the compelling factor in this issue
best in trial is it possible for a
person to have an Affliction some sort
of condition which might also speed up
the process of acidosis it's possible
what might some of those conditions mean
stress coronary disorder or cerebral
disorder the process would be more rapid
it's possible to have a serious coronary
condition where the initial warning
signals were so mild as to escape a
physician during a routine medical exam
oh nicely done
there would still be symptoms though
there are hundreds of chest pains
yes shortness of breath yes fatigue
passing out all the time
yes yes would you read your handwritten
remarks at the bottom page please sir
initial testing negative patient
complains of chest pains shortness of
breath and fatigue
restricted from running distances over
five miles for one week
isn't it possible that Santiago had a
serious coronary condition and not some
mysterious poison that caused the
accelerated chemical reaction
no
why private Santiago was given a clean
bill of health because Lord knows if you
put a man with a serious coronary
condition on duty with a clean bill of
health and that man died from a heart
related incident you'd have a lot to
answer for when you oh boy your honor we
renew our objection to Commander Stone's
testimony and ask that it be stricken
from the record the objections of a rule
Council move to reconsider the witness
is an expert and the court will hear his
opinion the witness doesn't make
mistakes Monday the 19th at which time
the defense will call its first Witness
I strenuously object
objection overruled no no no no no no I
strenuously
why do you hate them so much they
tortured and tormented a weaker kid they
didn't like him so they killed him and
why because he couldn't run very fast
everybody take the night off go see your
wife see your daughter Joe go do
whatever it is you do when you're not
a great time
why do you like them so much
because they stand on a wall
and they say nothing's going to hurt you
tonight not on my watch smart this is so
rooted and not just what are the facts
but what is the belief yeah
and how can you spin the perspective
juries are swayed by emotion more than
anything else
I was wondering if how you'd feel about
my taking you to dinner tonight
are you asking me out on a date no I've
been asked down in dates before and
that's what it sounded like do you like
seafood I know a good seafood place
I think you're an exceptional liar I
watch the Court members they respond to
you I see you convincing them and I
think Dawson and Downey are going to end
up owing their lives to you phenomenon
of spending mine with
I think you should prepare yourself for
the fact that we're going to lose
whoa I mean let's pretend for a minute
then it would actually matter to this
corner
I can't prove it ever happened and we'll
put on a show but at the end of the day
all we have is a testimony of two people
accused of murder Jack Nicholson that's
right
that's what we'll find the truth gonna
be the account I want the truth
when the time is right when we are ready
have you ever received a code red yes
sir we were doing seven man assault
drills and my weapon slipped this guy
from ER there you go it's private
Santiago ever late for platoon meetings
yes sir was this Barracks ever disorder
yes sir you got a code red because your
palms were sweaty why didn't Santiago
this burden to his unit ever get one
exactly yeah
Dawson wouldn't allow it to the guys
talked tough about Santiago but they
wouldn't go near him Jeffrey did you
ever want to give Santiago a code red
yes sir why didn't you because Dawson
would kick my butt sir
I hold here the Marine outline for
recruit training you familiar with this
book yes sir would you turn to the
chapter that deals with code Reds please
just flip to the page in the book that
discusses code Reds they're not in there
well you see sir code red is a term that
we use is there no book no manual or
pamphlet no set of orders or regulations
it lets me know that as a marine one of
my duties is to perform code red you
know the answer no sir
no book sir I love how he's answering so
sincerely no
to see how things work would you turn to
the page in this book that says where
the mess hall is please
well Lieutenant Caffey that's not in the
book sir
[Laughter]
that's so good
how did you know where the mess hall was
if it's not in this book
well I guess I just followed the crowd
at child time sir ah good answer
thank you sir
Oh you mean he's a little impressed
that's good that was well pleased I'm
gonna use that later
I want to slam dunk this guy 1900 every
time there's another courtroom he's like
we're gonna lose we're gonna lose
my freaking ass off let that be a movie
moment for their life of what the [__]
oh is it uh what's his name yeah
I know everything was it a code red yes
did Kendra give the order yes he was
never going to be transferred off that
base
[Music]
we're going to McDonald's they need some
food to stock Cocoa Puffs you've got the
transport it's got your signature I know
I signed him the morning you arrived in
Cuba five days after Santiago died I
don't want a deal
and I don't want immunity I want
McDonald's
Jessup said that six the next morning
was a first flight Santiago could have
left on markinson says there was a plane
that left seven hours earlier you just
concentrate on Downey I'm gonna talk to
Ross tell them where we are is is that
guy going to die I don't want him to die
I don't I feel like he'll be exonerated
I'm going optimistic and I want to tell
you that I think oh [__] bunch of you
are certifiably insane this code of
honor of yours makes me want to beat the
[__] out of something
I'm your friend and I'm telling you I
don't think your clients belong in jail
but I don't get to make that decision
wow now I want you to acknowledge that
the Judge Advocate has made you aware of
the possible consequences involved in
accusing a marine officer of a felony
without proper evidence I've been so
advised it's true we were here to
witness that you got bullied into that
courtroom by the memory of a dead lawyer
Papa can you hear me
Lance corporal Dawson's ranking after
the school of infantry was perfect
what's Dawson's promotion held up
because of this last report
I'm sure it was could you read it you
recall an incident
involving a PFC Curtis Bell who'd been
found stealing liquor from the Officers
Club did you report private bill the
proper authorities the only proper
authorities I am aware of are my
Commanding Officer Colonel Nathan R
Jessup and the Lord our God
I knew that was coming Lieutenant do you
know what a code red is yes I do have
you ever ordered a code red no I have
not
did you order Dawson two other men to
make sure the private Bell received no
food except water he was given water and
vitamin supplements and I can assure you
at no time was his health in danger
sure it was lovely for private bill
[Laughter]
sick to eat vitamins with no food
wouldn't this form of discipline be
considered code red no if I called the
other 478 Marines at Guantanamo Bay to
testify would they consider it a code
red well he's a court the witness
Lieutenant Kendrick was Dawson given a
rating of below average on this last
report because you learned him in
sneaking food to private Bell object not
so fast
Lieutenant I want to hear that one yeah
he disobeyed an orders because he made a
decision about the welfare of a marine
that was in conflict with an order of
yours he was punished is that right but
the code Marine if you had ordered
Dawson to give Santiago a code red I
specifically ordered those messages
disobeyed you again Lieutenant don't
answer that you don't have to I'm
through
to order Lance corporal Dawson and
private Downey to give Willy Santiago a
code red
always hesitating
no I did not thank you I'll tell you
hesitated
he was rattled the first flight
Stateside left Guantanamo Bay at 2300 it
arrived at Andrews Air Force Base
Maryland is a few minutes past two in
the morning what are you telling me you
fixed the logbook that's the only
conclusion you don't still intend to put
me on the stand Thursday morning 10
o'clock oh boy it was bad well but
Marcus didn't understand and we'll deal
with jessup's refusal to transfer
Santiago and he'll testify to the forage
transfer and that'll be enough that and
downy's testimony really ought to be
enough I feel like something's really
going to happen to him I feel like he's
not going to make it to the trial I was
ordered to give him a code red by the
platoon commander of rifle security
company Windward Lieutenant Jonathan
James Kendrick you're gonna do fine
sure do you remember the order of the
questions yeah are you sure yes I know
you small words yes because he gets
Rattle and he doesn't understand so I'm
just saying go slow I'm gonna go slow
okay
building building
Dear Mr and Mrs Santiago
I was William's executive damn it damn
it he's gonna do it isn't it I was
really worried to do this I wasn't
strong enough to stop it always
Lieutenant Colonel Matthew Andrew
markinson damn it man
[Music]
why did you go to private Santiago's
room a code red was ordered by my
platoon Commander Lieutenant Jonathan
James Kendrick you're Witness
dark and stormy night the pickup private
got a flat sir right at 39 he pulled up
and Bam blowout with no spare I'm
guessing it must be a good hour by foot
am I right pick of him he did it in 45
Flats sir
good man an order that Lieutenant
Kendrick gave you in your barracks room
in 1620 am I right yes sir
what you just said that you didn't make
it back to the windward Barracks until
1645. oh damn it well you see sir there
was a blowout private did you ever
actually hear Lieutenant Kendrick order
of Code Red well Hal said that private
did you ever oh no why did you go into
Santiago witness has right the witness
has been read his rights Commander the
question will be repeated
Santiago's room
always turn into hell now carpet answer
the captain's question
woof
as Captain I was given an order by my
squad leader Lance corporal Harold W
Dawson United States Marine Corps and I
followed it
does look up to him huh yup damn it guys
Danny wasn't in his room that was an
important piece of information don't you
think Danny it was a setback but we fix
it and move on to markinson markinson's
dead yeah really gotta handle those
Federal Marshals boy
this guy
got into full dress uniform
stood in the middle of that room drew a
nickel-plated pistol from his holster
fired a bullet into his mouth
why did you ask Jessup for the transfer
order you could have gotten it by
picking up the phone and calling any one
of a dozen departments at the Pentagon
you wanted to see jessup's reaction when
you asked for the transfer order exactly
what possible good could come from
putting Jessica
told Kendrick to order the code red
that's great why didn't you say so and
of course you have proof
well for our defendants it's a lifetime
at exotic Fort Leavenworth it's a car
Marshall yes Johnny after falsely
accusing a highly decorated marine
officer of conspiracy
oh gosh
jeez thank you for playing should we or
should we not follow the advice of the
galactically stupid
all is not lost this is not the Dark
Night of the soul that is required right
now
that's how you know you're almost to the
victory I'm sorry I lost your set of
steak knives
woof [__] and this a picture of me in
the shower
wrote a paper about your father in
college one of the best trial lawyers
ever and if I were Dawson and Downing I
had a choice between you your father to
represent me in this case I'd choose you
any day of the week and twice on Sunday
oh
10 times the lawyer Mufasa was could you
put chess up on the stand nope
not a Lionel caffeine or Sam Weinberg
our lead counselor for the defense in
the matter of U.S versus Dawson and down
you are ma'am
wwtcd joke get in the car Joanne please
get in the car
[Music]
we got him got a little jog
I'm gonna put Jessup on the stand
kiss me full Hollywood this movie's so
effective at knowing to keep Jack
Nicholson as more of a looming presence
and build him up threaten the Shadows
yeah he's always so powerful yeah and I
think he's pissed off that he's got to
hide from this I think he wants to say
that he made a Command Decision and
that's the end of it he eats breakfast
300 yards away from 4 000 Cubans that
are trained to kill him he's doing a
technical center
I need my bad I think better with my
back where's my back toss me about put
it in the closet don't ever put that bat
in the closet
what's in that closet what did you see
oh there's evidence hidden back here
magical bat
[Music]
Sam I need you to do something for me
blowing this thing wide open you feel
like he's not gonna say it don't go for
it you could get in trouble
oh you're not suggesting that I back off
a material witness if you think you
can't get him yeah given that extra
ounce of steaks yeah light that fire oh
man he's gonna risk it all
where's Sam he's on his way
he's got some piece of evidence he's
coming gotta get the truth even though
he can't handle it
the witness is aware the court is aware
but we thank you for bringing this to
our attention move on Lieutenant yes sir
who are those guys uh they're gonna blow
this thing wide open
I ordered markinson to have Santiago
transferred off the base immediately I
felt his life might be in danger once
word of the letter got out
grave Danger
is there another kind
not into guantanamos Santiago's Barracks
room was sealed off and its contents
inventory I'm wondering why Santiago
wasn't packed
your honor these are the telephone
records from gitmo for September 6th and
these are 14 letters that Santiago wrote
in nine months oh my goodness upon
hearing the news that he was finally
getting his transfer Santiago was so
excited that do you know how many people
he called
zero nobody
he was asleep in his bed at midnight and
according to you he was getting on a
plane in six hours
yet everything he owned was hanging
neatly in his closet and folded neatly
in his foot lock oh yes guys get
scripted
you packed a bag and made three phone
calls Santiago was leaving for the rest
of his life
and he hadn't called a soul and he
hadn't packed a thing
that's good that's [__] good Santiago
wasn't going anywhere isn't that right
Colonel now it's my recommendation sir
that Lieutenant Kathy be reprimanded for
his conduct and the witness be excused
with the Court's deepest I know the
judge looks like he's uh
your objection is noted I'm gonna keep
an eye on this I want the truth colonel
maybe he was an early riser and like to
pack in the morning these two marines
are on trial for their lives
please tell me that their lawyer hasn't
pinned their hopes to a phone bill
Jesus
thanks Danny I love Washington excuse me
let me dismiss you I'm not through with
my examination
sit down
I always made a choice I'd appreciate if
he would dress me as Colonel or sir I
believe I've earned it he probably did
that intentionally
that's when I developed my drinking
problem the witness will address this
court as judge or your own I'm quite
certain I've earned it oh [__] he's
losing respect stripping him down you
don't own this trip his pride down this
isn't your office your honor these are
the tower Chiefs logs for both
Guantanamo Bay and Andrews Air Force
Base I don't understand you're admitting
evidence of a flight that never existed
well we believe it did Sir there's the
where's the mistake they were working
the ground crew at Andrews at 2AM on
seven oh [__] Colonel a moment ago check
the tower logs for Christ's sake well
we'll get to the Airman in just a minute
sir
you know let's just get it to him
and Lieutenant Kendrick was clear on
what you wanted Crystal any chance
Lieutenant Kendrick left your office
said the old man is wrong no never we
follow orders or people die it's that
simple
are we clear
and people are we clear crystal crystal
yes
if you gave an order that Santiago
wasn't to be touched
and your orders are always followed and
why would Santiago be in danger
why would it be necessary to transfer
him off the base
great question you said he was being
transferred because he was in grave
danger that's correct you said he was in
danger I said grave danger you said
Israel
your own words in Lieutenant Kendrick
gave an order that Santiago wasn't to be
touched
and why did he have to be transferred
tenant Kinder quoted the code red Denny
because that's what you told Lieutenant
Kendrick to do object when it went back
cut these guys loose
oh [__] did you order the code right you
don't have to answer that question I'll
answer the question oh God you want
answers I think I'm entitled it's coming
true you you can't handle the truth yeah
you have the luxury of not knowing what
I know that Santiago's death while
tragic probably saved lives oh [__] I
don't give a damn what you think you are
entitled to did you order the code red I
did the job
you're goddamn right I did yes
I suggested members be dismissed so that
we can move to an immediate article 39a
session
the witness has rights
Captain Ross
give me
a second approach Genesis imploding case
called him jack his friend damn that's a
great scene that was a tremendous true
climax MP's got the colonel yes sir
whoa getting arrested man I'm being
charged with a crime a trial by Court
martial is that what this is or
administrative I'm being charged with a
crime oh God this is Spence I'm gonna
rip the eyes out of your head and visit
your Dead skull
oh [__] Jesus you put people's lives in
danger you got a man sweet dreams son
don't call me son
I'm a lawyer and an officer in the
United States Navy I am the son of a
very and you're under arrest you son of
a [__]
the witness is excused
you've got a man killed you've got one
of your own killed in a minute to slow
my heart down it's crazy how like that
one scene does live up to like you're
like no wonder that's a quote Yeah it's
like such a crescendo what comes after
this Powerhouse active yeah I don't know
what happens after that
on the charge of murder
the members finally accused not guilty
one you won the charge of conduct
Unbecoming a United States Marine guilty
as charged
and you are ordered to be dishonorably
discharged from the Marine Corps you got
punished for the thing though that you
said you were okay with getting punished
for yeah they did kill a man
I mean yeah following orders is not a
good excuse Colonel Jessica
episode Red what did we do wrong it's
not that simple what did we do wrong we
did nothing wrong yeah we did we did it
he was supposed to fight for people who
couldn't fight for themselves
he was supposed to fight for Willie oh
poor guys hey man we're in charge for
murder them you don't need to wear a
patch in your arm to have honor
10 hot there's an officer one day
oh
[Music]
uh
the real verdict is respect Cameron
cecilom Allen Anthony Rodriguez what
exactly were these guys going to testify
to unless I'm mistaken they're both
going to testifying or oath that they
had absolutely no recollection of
anything they just needed to sit in the
courtroom
where's your legacy sequel Tom
yeah good Jack Nicholson out of
retirement for one more
who did he kill on the inside
[Music]
damn
what a film yeah that was great yeah
that was fantastic
still that
feels Timeless truly let's do the math
here
10 20 30 years ago 31 okay yeah 92's
came out yeah yeah 31 years ago
and that holds up like I don't know just
as much as it ever did especially you
know being that it surrounds like
Guantanamo Bay and that just makes Tom
Cruise's
face today that much more impressive
than what he does today though
holy [__] it's 31 years ago this guy's
business a long time
uh yeah now I thought it was an
incredibly compelling story like I love
a good courtroom drama and it they made
they made it very like character driven
and had all the heart and nuance and
yeah do I think like Aaron Sorkin is is
a little bit more
a little bit more Punchy and more fun
now I think this is quip energy there's
like a sort of Aaron Sorkin energy you
know like that there's a stabilization
of his dialogue over time that is
present here but is less like in your
face yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's this
this doesn't feel like something I would
say about Tarantino like this doesn't it
feels like a Sorkin script but nowadays
you can like watch something and be like
that Aaron's working right this way yeah
whereas this feels just like um you know
like a a passion piece that got him off
the ground because like I said at the
beginning it's based on a play and then
it got made into a movie and I I think
here it was it was a phenomenal piece of
work uh the the acting all around was
amazing and the other thing I really
knew about it was Aaron silicon wrote it
and stars Tom Cruise Demi Moore and Jack
Nicholson I wasn't aware of how little
Jack Nicholson would be in here but
whenever he's here he's such an
effective presence and the fact do you
kind of keep him in the shadows makes
whenever he shows up that actually that
much more threatening versus checking in
with him a bunch because everyone else
is constantly building up the hierarchy
the ranks uh the
it's like it explores this this line of
when does it become you know a code
amongst your Brotherhood and when is it
just a cult you know yeah yeah exactly
and what is you know following the
reasonable chain of command versus what
is something that you know morally you
should object to even though it might
lead to you know protocol based uh you
know repercussions or or Consequences or
something like that like it's you know
it's it's the examination of you know at
what point should you not just follow
orders and you see the danger
represented nicely between the two
defendants because you have the one that
is clearly I keep mixing their names up
but you have the one that's clearly like
much more uh outwardly intelligent and
and clearly the losses sort of yeah in
charge and then you have the other one
who you know is is gonna follow whatever
this guy says and trusts him and so it's
like yeah you've got these two people
you know on the hook for this one of
whom is just following his buddy who he
looks up to and the other one who thinks
he's doing The Honorable thing and uh
and yeah it's like it's it's great
because I think the way they lay
everything out you know they give you
just enough to know what the truth is
but also to see just how murky it is
from a law standpoint from a legal
standpoint yeah I let you they let the
audience get involved with the
complicated nature of what everything is
going on like they let you have the
discussion and kind of go well yeah I
mean I'm not really
sure what's right or right it's not
black and white like that's why I think
the punishment served at the end is not
this romantic Hollywood ending yeah of
they get off of it and they just get a
second chance at life you know like they
get a punishment but they also get a
clear their name of being murderers you
know I thought that was really well
orchestrated to go down that path
because you even have it amongst the the
def the the defense team the defense
Council you know they they all have like
you got Debbie Moore who's incredibly
empathetic and sensitive to this
situation then you got Kevin Pollock who
is uh repulsed by the situation he
believes they deserve to serve time in
court and he finds their actions
um abhorrent and you got Tom Cruise
who's the one going through the massive
character trajectory Arc of someone
who's just like I'm just here to do a
job let's call it quits let's call it a
day it's just another case and then he's
fighting himself getting really
emotionally entangled yeah over the
course of this and finding something to
care more about uh than just himself
just doing a job just to get it over
with I think
the way they and but the way they have
the discussion around the particular
case like it's a fascinating subject
because normally we're dealing with like
a crime was committed yeah and it is
that it is it is life and death it is a
crime was committed that it's all
circling around this thing I've never
heard of before I don't know if it's a
real thing
um but the code red subject yeah I've
never I've never heard I mean yeah they
have of course it's like a hazing yeah
of course seen movies amazing with
discipline yeah
um yeah but I'm not I'm not familiar
with that specific terminology are you
I'm not no I don't know if that's like a
thing they made up here or if that's
based on some real sort of Unwritten
military code or something like that
yeah yeah and I I like how it um it
deals with the subject matter of is that
okay to do like I feel like that's a
real thing in in some even if it's not
exactly what it's called code red I feel
like there's some truth to that type of
discipline yeah that's sort of like the
unit has to discipline each other other
as a means of pulling closer together
and also being independent enough but
also in line with their superiors but
they even have a um they even have a
gray area with that of how sometimes
it's been affected like they had that
Noah something the guy who plays in an
ER yeah Noah I don't know his last name
yeah
um I think it's Noah it's his first name
I can almost see it
um but when he was there he was when he
was testifying he was saying like no it
helped him become a better Soldier and
like he's even laughing about it like he
the way he looks back on that memory of
receiving the code red punishment he's
smiling about it he looks back on it
fondly like he grew as a person due to
it yeah yeah
um
but you know like everyone else is being
what they're exploring here that other
people are are falling behind and [__]
you know uh or they're they're slacking
here this this guy this guy who was who
was killed he wanted to be out he wanted
to be transferred like it's it's a
completely different thing and it's and
that's where the cultish mentality comes
in of no you're gonna we're just gonna
Stick it to you you know yeah well it's
clearly a matter of yeah he's not just
you know a bit sloppy or disengaged it's
like this is actually kind of a threat
and detriment to his health and
well-being he's been misdiagnosed by the
doctor he's passing out all over the
place and and you know you only get a
brief glimpse of him when he's alive but
that one scene in the mess hall you can
just feel how like isolated and alone
this dude is when also simultaneously
being forced to you know harmonize with
a bunch of other people who are being
you know he's being sort of unfairly you
know put into these circumstances where
everybody and and then expect it to
perform alongside everybody else and so
yeah like I I love the whole I just the
the whole deceit of the debate about
them basically saying like no we got to
keep him here like you know it's uh if
we transfer him that's only gonna lead
like like I it's so despicable but it
becomes like the exact opposite argument
to the public versus internally when
they're like yeah no we gotta you know
Hammer this guy down and you know shape
him and mold him and we can't you know
accept
no for an answer basically on that front
yeah and it's it's fun seeing what Jack
Nicholson did with this role of a guy
who's just so set in his old school ways
and refuses to if even though there's
like a law implemented which I think is
smart to put in the movie again I don't
know what's actual truth too that is
reflective or what's made up here it
would all be based on something but I
think that's smart because that
immediately tells you what they did is
illegal yeah like regardless what they
did is illegal so you're telling the
audience it's certainly wrong so there's
no question about it because it's good
it is it is illegal what they're doing
this is not on the books so let it go
yeah so I think that was that was very
clever but
um yeah I think Jack Nicholson makes for
a quite a formidable villain like Demi
Moore's presence here I think that it
was great that they did not actually
have her hook up with Tom Cruise yeah I
was just thinking that um because when
they started going the seafood data I
was like uh here we go here's the
Hollywood yeah at the end they're gonna
kiss yeah they're like this is gonna be
the start of a beautiful relationship
I'm really glad it didn't go down that
path because that would have I think
undercut the movie quite a bit and her
character too yeah it would it would
have underserved her character the
tension is enough to to add some
character Stakes but yeah it's it's not
so much that it eclipses the actual
point of why we're all here and and yeah
like I like that you know even though
there are moments where people are being
unprofessional or or whatever you know
they're mostly sticking to the case and
the proceedings and you know unraveling
all of that and responding to the
emotional ups and downs of the case
rather than like interpersonal
melodramas and things like that well I
think the arc for uh the Dany characters
well constructed too because so much of
this is about you know dealing with uh
your higher ups mentors whatever it may
be answering to some type of authority
Legacy yeah and he is dealing so much
with uh living in his father's Shadow
and having him make his own identity in
his own choices as well and they don't I
mean they take moments to like talk
about it so it's clear to the audience
but there's not like a horde amount of
scenes that are dedicated to it yeah but
his personal Arc is reflective of the uh
decision making that the people he's
defending have had to deal with too you
know so while they're different
different subjects you can see how
thematically they're similar so I
thought that was that even though it's a
it's definitely an archetype of what
that especially now I don't know like
preceding this movie How often that was
the case but after this movie for sure
seeing that kind of art type a billion
times yeah living in your father's
Shadow uh which is a fine archive to me
because it's like a thing a lot of a lot
of people deal with
um and I thought that was a perfect
choice though for why for to reflect the
whole movie thematically overall oh yeah
um because you know like within the
Marines
any type of military unit you become
family with people so I'm told by all
them uh you it is like a family and
you're in the shadow of your Superior
officer who's sort of like you know a
dad of sorts even with the um even with
the two who have to defend themselves
that is
that doesn't feel like soldiers it feels
like an older brother taking care of a
younger brother who's not as capable you
know yeah 100 so they kind of strip away
a lot of the a lot of this is like
stripping away the the actual Law and
Order and the codes it's just stripping
away the pageantry and the protocol and
the formality of the situation yeah
really just cutting down to the facts
into the morality at Play
you know and the and yeah like the
inherent risks and negligences that went
into this and and yeah the just the way
the these machinations can you know lead
to these like really horrible nasty
things that often just slide under the
radar and yeah it's like it's just one
person compared to however many and like
you know even Nicholson you know being
the antagonist so to speak or at least
you know sort of the the Pinnacle as of
this case of you know
the real intent uh I thought they still
managed to draw him in a way where like
yeah we're not really supposed to like
get on board with or agree with him but
I
didn't feel the movie too much
hating the character on our behalf if
that makes any sense like we see him
from a limited perspective but I don't
know I I really thought Jack Nicholson
inhabited him like he's got all of his
jackness he's got that sort of thing
where you're like oh yeah this guy's
probably not a Savory dude but at the
same time I could see how he would arise
these ranks with respect and get to the
position he's in in as hellish of a
place as it seems Guantanamo Bay would
be well the movie does a good job along
with his performance and especially the
writing of him because yeah you know
they always say like a good villain
doesn't believe he's the villain of the
story he always believes he's right
right he believes he's actually the
protagonist and he's this guy certainly
does
to the point though where it's like
parts of it are very convincing and like
this movie rides a Gray Line uh with a
lot of the subject matter including all
the things the characters are dealing
with but especially with Jack
Nicholson's character you know like yeah
I don't know what it must be like to
like when the way he's talking about
like all these the general public and
all the fanciness that we have to put up
here like you said pageantries that's
what the world sees but they don't know
they really don't understand the kind of
ugliness that we live in they'll never
be able to comprehend the harshness we
deal with and every fear that we have to
live with so yeah sometimes we have to
make some ugly decisions because that
ugly decisions what keeps this country
safe I'm like yeah I mean I I cannot
fathom
how hard the decision-making must be and
what it must do to kind of make you a
little bit colder and a little bit more
ruthless because that ruthlessness is
what keeps you alive so yeah I have no
idea so when you're hearing them like I
get that point yeah oh yeah that's part
of what makes that climactic scene so
great is like you don't agree with him
and you know that his actions directly
led to this man's death and that should
be you know Justice should be served
there but at the same time you're like
no I get I get where you're coming from
though I can't fathom half the [__]
you're talking about I wouldn't want to
be in your position whatsoever and I can
only assume that there is no good way to
go about any of this yeah and so yeah at
least yeah I thought across the board
like the characterizations were very
graceful and very well fleshed and all
the actors I thought across the board
were well Chosen and did a fine job and
yeah like I would be fascinated I can
kind of Envision how this might be a
play I can imagine sort of like okay
maybe you'd have the courthouse set the
office you know the little house where
they're you know breaking down the case
and maybe a couple other sort of you
know interstitial things but it does
really seem like you know this
transforms into you know a move like I
would be fascinated to know what is
different how much of this you know is
directly transcribed or not because
again I would if you didn't tell me that
this was a play I would have never
guessed well I imagine this that's for a
Rob Reiner skills really came in handy
here sure of being able to go we need
them to travel we need to see them
travel we need to see them outside
because most of this movie is is in
interior locations most of this movie is
people just having conversations at
interior in like the last half is mainly
the courtroom case
and but you know they got certain
moments where like they're traveling to
a base they're in a car you know and so
and little things like that but even on
the interior scenes they never felt like
they were just a play no and that's my
problem with most play adaptations is
I'm like I might as well just watch the
play too now watching famous people yes
yeah I'm watching Hollywood actors
instead of Broadway actors yeah uh and
and yeah I thought the way that they
also
I think it's especially s you know of a
movie the way that they show you the
facts of the case and they show you just
enough it's like they show the two guys
breaking in on Santiago in the beginning
and just you know the beginning of that
situation and then we cut to the
aftermath of that situation we see a
couple of like perspectives on Santiago
that you could get from just other you
know soldiers that counts and then
you're in the room when you know the the
order comes down from Jack Nicholson and
that's it's like enough to for us to
know the truth but it's also enough to
accentuate the idea that like well if
this one guy is obviously Kiefer
Sutherlands not gonna cave to this line
of questioning and uh and uh TJ Nelson
Has removed himself like yeah you can
you can see it's like they don't show
you the whole thing but they give you
just enough of the facts and just enough
of the you know fly on the wall
perspectives to be like I know the truth
and it I also know how this does look as
bleak can dire and impossible as they
say because it does just ride on one guy
verifying this account yeah and I
thought it was great too that they left
they don't actually
confirm that he gave the code red order
like you know yeah but they you don't
have anyone you had they cast doubts on
the uh
manowitz Markowitz the guy who ended up
unaliving himself yeah they cast doubts
about his okay even though you're like
no no he's definitely telling the truth
but the fact that you just don't even
give us a scene where you the way how
they gave us the scene of when he is
talking with Kiefer Sutherland and stuff
about what to do with Santiago I love
that they waited for that Mo they've
waited for the finale for him to to
finally affirm it yeah it's like you get
the initial deceit of him being like no
I'll transfer this guy we're gonna say
we're gonna transfer the guy but yeah
not getting the actual account of
whether he gave the order yeah you know
um and
I really do like
I thought I might find it distracting to
see Tom Cruise
no and I was like no this is he's he's
great in this he's so believable yeah
and I've transported to Tom Cruise of
this time because he's been a great
actor for a very long time and I think
now more than ever you feel like you're
just watching talkers but um but because
he kind of does play like a certain type
all the time maybe this was like the
type he played back then this is like a
young hot shot who has to you know rise
it's really good at what he does when
you get him invested because he did that
like The Color of Money uh Top Gun this
I'm like well looking back at his
younger like this was the kind of rules
I guess he would do but this is yeah but
even more than Color of Money which had
a lot of physical aspects to it with him
playing pool if you look at Top Gun um
you know obviously the plane flight
sequences the aerial sequence is there
here it is just acting he's that's all
he's doing is it is pure acting right
here and he's acting his ass off in a
way that is a very human performer a lot
of charm yeah he's got his big moments a
lot of it is just like a guy he's just a
natural guy yeah and I I I've been
wanting for a long time for Tom Cruise
to kind of just go back to
dude I'm like forming will the public
want that maybe not like we're so we we
expect him in these like huge summer
movies and it's what saved his career
after you know um tainting his puppy his
personal and yeah after attaining his
personal image where he was putting his
love life in religious life on you know
full display
and then people are still always trying
to expose him for that you know and he's
managed to like make everyone shut up
about it because he keeps like trying to
kill himself on screen here
can you forget about my problematic
aspects now and uh I I love I love the
movies he does and I love I love the Tom
Cruise we have today but I've never
forgotten like he's an amazing actor
though and and a lot of that is
overshadowed by you know the crazy
stunts he pulls off and now yeah and
this is just a reminder such a testament
to him yeah he's he's a phenomenal actor
and nikoi said the action Daniel
Day-Lewis and the drama Jackie Chan is
but wouldn't Daniel did you lose just be
the drama Daniel Day Lewis and Jackie
Chan
sure but this this this was this was the
doctors doesn't become these people yeah
the people become he's a very emotional
he's committed he's committed but he
doesn't stay in character yeah between
tapes like I think he does a full backs
I know I know his acting method is he
does a full back story he loves to know
the entire character's history like he
really does love to know the whole
lineage of how this character came to be
so he knows his character's thinking and
feeling in this very moment so I I do
believe that
um but you know like there's a but he
knows how to like turn it off when it's
not yeah the camera's not when it's not
his yeah he seems like the kind of guy
who who especially as a producer and
stuff needs to keep the set as pleasant
as possible so he can't afford to be the
character off screen that heavily yeah
yeah but you know I feel like now it's
there's a certain type of Lady and
that's that was kind of what was fun
about him in Top Gun Maverick was it was
a little bit bringing it back to the
performer yeah yeah that he's like oh
he's he's kind of just he's a guy he's
just a guy he's not like action leading
hero yeah though he has those scenes he
feels like a relatable guy really
skilled guy yeah in a tangible position
and and I think here it's it's really
fun it's a fun time capsule to watch
because it is
you know you kind of witnessed the
lightning in a bottle of Tom Cruise
because it has that Duality to his
performance where on the one hand you're
like this is like a textbook what people
think of when they think of a Tom Cruise
performance he's got the smile you know
he's got this you know the sort of messy
but Suave attitude he's in a you know
position of power obviously he's you
know a a lawyer for the Armed Forces but
uh at the same time it also just feels
like that was right for the character
and that's Danny you know he's a care
you're really rooting for him to win
you're rude like when he has that moment
when he has to choose like I thought
they set the stage just nicely but there
it wasn't just like Demi Moore just
showed up to introduce Stakes like they
were they were setting that up yeah
um throughout the film like you you
press a certain you know uh high
official too hard then you're gonna
you're gonna get like this barred you
know um and
that moment where he had to choose
you're like I'll [__] choose yeah I
did make the choice we want you to make
like you really root for him in this
movie it's been a while since I've
really rooted for him that yeah didn't
involve like you know save the day and
then yeah and a scenario in which I
think when it becomes the bigger the
stakes become I think the more of a
foregone conclusion it is that he is
going to Prevail whereas something like
this feels so high stakes but if you
don't know you know if you haven't seen
it you it could go either way I mean
obviously when he gets the you know
ultimate climax out of Jack Nicholson
you know where it's going to go but for
so much of it like they they it's a
testament to the writing of the
character the performance by Tom Cruise
and the whole array of circumstances but
yeah like you really do sort of sweat
and you're like we need all of the
prowess of Tom Cruise to maybe have a
hope of scraping this by and that feels
real rather than just like you know yeah
it's exciting and it's death defying so
there's that element
and it's possible but you know he's
gonna be fine whereas here it's like I
don't know like this is yeah it's a
different playing field it's a little
more grounded it's still like as it's
got a it's still like thrilling like I
do appreciate a movie like this because
like I think a lot of legal dramas are
quite engrossing and enjoyable in many
ways but they're not always as like
you know something about this still
feels
action-packed almost even though you're
not watching like an action movie that's
a Sorkin writing man yeah exactly he
knows how to do that yeah he knows how
to keep things
he loves energy he loves fun and he
loves heart he loves having humor like I
love Aaron sorkin's writing I really I
really love his writing well and going
back to that thing you said earlier like
like being that this is you know an
earlier part in his career it still had
so much humor while also having you know
that heft and that researched you know
literary quality to it and you know this
was a a you know it's a heavy movie
Heavy circumstance but it was a lot more
like enjoyable there was a lot more you
know I thought we were walking into that
too yeah I thought we were walking into
like a heavy drama yeah and it's like
it's not funny but it's like it's funny
the way like life is funny you know like
yeah it's it's there's charm in life and
in the between moments you know between
uh you know big intense testimony or
whatever they're gonna be some lighter
moments and yeah it felt very natural
and it also happens to play on Tom
Cruise's again natural sort of Charisma
charismatic charm yeah I was just saying
it's good with dialogue he's great with
dialogue like let him act yeah
he's good at committing and being
sincere and again like he's just got it
he just has the yeah he just has that
that movie star thing I hope when he
realizes like you know I am a senior
citizen
I should probably dialed back some of
this stuff up to her house when he does
get to that point he just he just
continues to go back to you know I'm
acting again every three years let's
just put it in time make it sound like I
don't love what he does now because I I
am in love with what he does now it's
just yeah I'm talking even just go back
to the collateral you know yeah like
just that's not that far along like even
collateral well there was action in
there like that's a performance yeah
something that's a little more grounded
that rests more heavily on the
performance than on the physical and the
and the set pieces yeah yeah something
that really calls upon him to act and
also you know hopefully I mean not to
dog any big action movie but I think you
know the the smaller you scale it
potentially the more interesting the
character work may become and the
circumstances if they are more tangible
might be a little bit more vital and Tom
Cruise yeah I think it's I think that's
part of it is we're used to him now as
this God you know as this guy who is
willing to risk life and limb for Cinema
uh and I want a little bit more Tom
Cruise just the man again because this
is like a a great reminder of how
wonderful that can also be and I know he
still I know he's an older guy now but
he's still got all of the assets that
he's showcased in this movie The
performances of what he does now are
very much reflective of like I'm I've
been obsessed with Tom Cruise's like
life and career for a very long time and
I think the performances of what he does
now is very reflective of who he is as a
person in real life because he does have
this like insane hyper-focused Vigilant
um you know loves to learn type of
mentality like there there was if you've
watched there's one interview on like
Corden where he was rattling off the
amount of like licenses that he has for
the many things from you know a
helicopter plane a real estate license
like he's got a gazillion and he's
serious about that like he shot all
these things he loves to learn he and as
he he's a lawyer whereas a lot of past
the bar whereas a lot of celebrities
probably whereas a lot of celebrities as
they get more successful and famous they
kind of like to keep relaxing a fine
ways to like calm down and relax a
little bit more and have fun gain some
weight whatever yeah yeah he's used that
those opportunities to become smarter
more educated more of this like machine
and anyone who's on set he would love to
like learn what the crew was doing and
stuff and and inquire and really absorb
and that's that's the best way to
probably describe him is he is like a
sponge and yeah so what he does now is
this um you know accumulation of all the
things he's learned over the year yeah
well yeah and he puts it on the big
screen like he learns these things and
he puts it on the big screen like and
that's what's what I love about what he
is now because dude you are watching Tom
Cruise
that he's learning but it's also got a
narrative put on top of it yeah he loves
to learn about all these things and and
and so I I love what he is now because
you do see that is like this is the most
Tom Cruise you're getting other than
like you're not listening to the
Scientology stuff but this is the most
stalkers you're getting uh it feels like
he never lost that hunger like you know
like as a younger actor yeah it's like
as a younger actor you know you gotta
acquire more skills and take risks and
try things and then you reach that point
where you're like fully arrived and
people just offer you whatever and I
feel like that can yeah like you said be
kind of an excuse to maybe you know ease
off the gas asked with that but I feel
like yeah Tom Cruise just like has
always had that yeah he's just he's an
extremist yeah yeah and it's just like
okay I'll learn this thing now I gotta
go learn some more things yeah you know
he is a really whatever beliefs he might
have that you might disagree with at the
end of the day he is they were is he it
seems to work and no wonder they want
him to be the poster boy for that
religion because look what he is saying
look what he is defying he constantly
gives all his praise and thinks like I
am this way because of this you know um
and I I feel like this
so it's like can he can he do something
like this again you know that's that's
the question though is he even
interested in something like this again
that's the uh yeah I mean that's the big
question to me and right now it doesn't
feel like it so much but what is I mean
right now it's Mission Impossible which
he's gonna do until he's 80. well
everything he does he puts his finger on
turns into Mission Impossible you know
no it does like so night and day was
Vision impossible what the [__] The
Mummy was mission Impossible
everything's Mission Impossible yeah
even when we roll I mean top gun
Maverick is its own thing but a lot of
the leeway to being able to make the
movie that they made was because
yeah it also at least carries that
aspect of he's gonna do some crazy [__]
yeah that's great yeah he's gonna risk
his life for us yeah I mean like it's
more of a risk I would imagine now
because you know doing a mission
impossible wherever he happens to be
doing it in franchise or out seems to be
like this safest Tom Cruise like part of
me does wonder if it's maybe a little
restricting being in that position where
you know Mission Impossible works but
what else do we know right now that like
just works for Tom Cruise and I mean
that's like a scary thing but like I
would love to see a swing at like
something more dramatic or comedic or
something yeah just a little bit more
comedy stuff for so long I've seen it
forever he is such an underrated comedic
actor he's pushing for uh Tropic Thunder
too or whatever he's in a highly back
for that highly underrated even here you
see this comedy chops I mean he's so
he's got great time he's a funny guy
he's really funny and he doesn't get a
chance to the Mission Impossible kind of
shows it now but you know topical
Maverick kind of shows it but he's an
underrated Community grudging into
Mission imposs like after seven odd
movies he could be fun sometimes yeah I
I really it is this is looking like a
time capsule of of the kind of
performances he used to do yeah and I
feel like the Jeremy wire time is when
he started morphing into
I'm the guy who just Smiles at
everything yeah sure like it's like he
would go from like really Charmed super
intense like those it was like these
this this big obvious Paradigm of
performances of like Jerry Maguire shows
that War of the Worlds shows it sure
where he's like I'm super charming and
smiling so I'm super against you know
yeah I guess that's the Nuance yeah this
seems to ride a gradual line that is
very much just sort of on the back of
the development this is very natural
yeah
like he's just a guy and I and I kind of
I don't know if he is I don't even know
if he he can do that now it's such a
thing he's not that in real life
not bad guy because I feel like nowadays
he has everything that's on display in
this movie but yeah like the natural
levels I would be curious to see like as
I feel like probably at this time he was
more like this kind of guy and then
who's like because it's such a fine line
to me because this says again this is
like it's a very Tom Cruise performance
but this is clearly not at the point
where yeah it is just like oh Tom Cruise
is doing the Tom Cruise thing even
though all the things are are present so
I feel like it could happen you can even
Jack Reacher
and it is like super Intense or like you
know the occasional levity and there's
like there's pretty hard lines between
those things yeah and so I would like I
would love to see it I would love to see
a movie where Tom Cruise has to go back
and be like how do I just be
how am I just a guy who am I just
naturally respond to the situation at
hand and there's no sort of global
threat involved yeah it's just in real
life a movie that doesn't make an
opportunity for him to have to run yeah
I think his part of the key because this
didn't really give him an opportunity
much at all to like do that much that's
physical
I just want to say too I love him and
Jerry Maguire and War of the Worlds
action I think it's great
I've seen more of the worlds you ever
seen Jerry Maguire no no one has shown
me the money wow you haven't seen Jerry
Maguire no it hit me on your list I know
because it hit me during this when you
show me the one at one point when you
were getting Junior showed up you said
you had me at hello
I know because it's a Tom Cruise related
quote Yeah it's just that's another it's
like you can't handle the truth it's
just one of those like things that has
been uh yeah you know yeah grafted into
my subconscious without the full context
yeah
I love that movie dude
um alrighty well I knew this would turn
into a Tom Cruise discussion ten minutes
I know when we get to the review we're
gonna be talking a lot about like what
happened to this guy yeah yeah
how far we've come because yeah it's a
fascinating tale of what he is
yeah all right guys well what do you
think about A Few Good Men leave your
thoughts down below what are your
nitpicks do you wish Tom Cruise would
kind of go back to doing roles like this
leave your thoughts down below
um thespian what time is it for us it is
late but hey not late enough to do a
patreon
or Hague if I ever needed to go to court
and I wanted someone to defend me it
would be you I would love for Tyler hay
to defend me because you see a big part
of having a lawyers more than just facts
and the evidence the information no you
gotta buy into the defense attorney You
Gotta Buy into their personality and you
were just so warm and friendly and
sincere and just so relaxed I feel like
they would even let you do it via Zoom
oh true I agree with anything
think no matter what they'd be like he's
got to be telling the truth listen
listen to this guy look how sweet he is
he's such a sweetheart this guy wouldn't
represent someone who's guilty no that's
not the Tyler Hague way everyone want to
just hang out with you they won't even
care to hear about the defense the jury
would stop you know they're like look we
believe you he's innocent the case is
thrown out tell us about you Tyler you
want to go grab some breakfast that's
what would happen let's play some games
Tyler thank you so much for defending us
at every turn I can't wait for you to
represent me am I murdered slash Thief
trial
yeah
murder slash Thief suspect Greg with the
best defense attorney in the damn
country Tyler Haig thank you buddy get
him off
[Music]